bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
greetings of peace how many hosts of the
D show the first and one of the only
Islamic TV talk shows in America going
on 500 episodes strong al hamdulillah
and there are a lot of people spreading
misinformation about Islam a lot of
Islamophobia is growing and they're able
to in a matter of several years raised
almost a hundred million dollars for
what for a good purpose no for a noble
cause no for distorting the truth for
calling people away from peace you know
Islam calls people to peace to have
peace with their Creator peace with
themselves and peace with humanity so
creating this fear and anxiety in people
having people look at Islam as the other
have having people look at Islam as the
boogeyman that's coming to get you but
when people turn into the DS show they
see this is absolutely not what we've
been seeing we have more of a chance of
dying from secondhand smoke we have more
of a chance getting bitten by a dog and
dying or getting get this getting killed
by our own furniture that's right so
people we need to get the facts out and
I'm going to LA we've been successful at
changing the perception that a lot of
people have and many people have
accepted this way of life and the work
continues I've hamdulillah so do your
part and contribute you know there are
multi billionaires out there with money
just overflowing from the bank accounts
if not multi-billionaires you also have
multi millionaires with one check with
one click of a button they can finish
this campaign and it always help when
the people who are doing the Dawa they
can have a clear and focus mindset they
don't have to worry about these
secondary issues they can just focus on
what they're doing and you have people
out there who are sponsoring so you know
what I got your back whatever it takes
to keep this going is done finish these
are the people that need to step forward
and if it's not contributing towards the
D show find an organization that is out
there promoting this piece promoting an
understanding edifying educating the
people about this Dean the
fastest-growing way of life in the world
that's right and support that cause so
you have
great opportunity here to contribute and
support the Dean show or any other
organization that you feel comfortable
with but do something do your part get
out there and share because if we really
care we're going to go ahead and share
and this is my message to you contribute
if you haven't already helped us to
continue the work and inshallah God
willing we can move forward all together
and get the wonderful rewards that the
crater is promised for those who
contribute towards the Dawa we'll see
you next time inshallah eid mubarak